right welcome to scrambled except this
one it's scrambled with a difference
because we're in the middle of an
amazing survive part and I'm gonna
scramble ace but it's not egg plural its
eggs singer
[Music]
look at that that's an ostrich egg
equivalent of two dozen eggs in there
now no there's only one way to get into
an ostrich egg and that's what this
[Music]
[Music]
we're in we're in
that's the how about them now into a
bowl first look at this
[Music]
give a little mix can reach the yolk is
some butter in first tablespoon of
butter from there
no seasoning in and then makes that
butter up now into the pan again nice
off man nice and hot wow this is a Bray
okay this is a traditional South African
grill so it's super hot and wanna go 30
seconds on one minute off one minute on
one minute off she goes there she goes
now have rich daddies
get in there now
next to that I've got some spring onions
little bit of chilli as well from in
Chile from there
start to mount 24 eggs let's go back
smack in
seriously
I can
but as nicely
comes from free how Britch Turkish now
before I put my chili scallions in there
now so so give a little more flavor
okay give that a little mix thank you
put the scallions and the chili in a
little bit earlier so get a little bit
of a sauce spiced going to this
scrambled egg now traditionally there's
such a wonderful influence of Sudha
so India combines implants like this
perfect little melting potterson the
chili will give the heat the scallions
will help cool down favor burst of the
eat together
smell that chili
nice and thick
that's incredible bridge that yo case
but the exciting thing for me is the
yield
maybe a buddy getting into it but
beautiful
tablespoon fresh in let's go cool it
down stop take some over cooking a nice
season over done and then him
to come together
now where's my amazing gamekeeper lonely
you ready
this is lonely
amazing gamekeeper troubled eggs now
I've never made scrambled eggs with
ostrich eggs before
yeah but they're incredibly rich yeah
yeah yeah
so tasty I've a little bit of chilli
nobody's scanning in there and then over
at the top as I know you guys like your
garnish chili tomatoes onion yes and
just let that sit now I know we've been
up way before breakfast
thank you that's trimble egg Austrey
style yeah yeah yes to the man now
because cross taste the chili hmm that's
that suppose you only do with the
ostrich eggs we just leave them in the
bush hmm then now I know we have to
collect them for some scrambled egg yeah
yeah pretty good
yes lonely long the best gamekeeper in
all of South Africa the only one let me
know in the comments what you think of
that amazing scrambled egg dish and if
you missed them charted trust me you can
watch it on the link below or on the Nat
Geo app
[Music]